it's the uh the 24th of November it's
the meeting of Northeast Derbyshire
District council's cabinet
um we've got several I think all cabinet
members in the in the room today as well
as several officers and some other
officers on the screen I'm not going to
go through all the names because there's
probably too many of us I'll move
straight on with the business
um apologies for absence first we
received Jenny
normally just received yeah okay thanks
Tom uh decorations of Interest are there
any from anyone
no okay uh minutes the last meeting are
we all happy to approve them as a true
and accurate record I'll I'll happily
move them yeah second goodbye Council
running all those in favor
okay that's carried and then we come to
the uh proposed overview and scrutiny
work programs and we don't have any of
the scrutiny chairs unfortunately in
attendance but Damon is going to just
give us a brief overview
[Music]
okay thank you chairs um are you serious
presenting this report on behalf of the
student chairs we've given their
they've given their apologies today so
the purpose of this report is to inform
cabinet of the proposed overview and
scrutiny work programs so the 22-23
municipal year
and ask that cabinet supports those work
programs so you'll find those appendix
1A
1B 1C and 1D so the work programs are
live documents and subject to change
throughout the course of a year
and it's therefore important that the
work programs remain realistic
manageable and have the capacity to
respond to new issues and developments
so for this reason the work programs
contain a mix of Standalone items and no
more than one in-depth piece of work or
a scrutiny review
so for this year the student reviews are
Leisure religions for older residents
that's a community scrutiny
environmental enforcement for
organizations scrutiny and business
engagement for growth scrutiny so that's
really all there for us me to say chairs
that's any members have any questions
thanks Damon uh any questions
no
um I think are we just asked to know
this report
uh of support
okay I'll I'll happily uh happily move
that then is there a secondary councilor
running all those in favor
okay that's Carrie thank you very much
yeah and then we come to the uh business
um sorry the tourism uh scrutiny review
um which I think is under canceled
Kenyans now are you okay to take that
Jeremy over to you
yeah thank you chair uh yes uh thank you
to the uh scrutiny committee for their
report and recommendations uh we've
worked through them and we're a set of
actions from that that we can take
um I would like to point out that the
the item that was reviewed is not a
statutory thing for the council to
perform and uh as such it it's uh has to
be somewhat more flexibly resource
should we say and we've had one crisis
after another and we're now in the
middle of a cost of living one so
um there is an element of doing what we
can rather than
um it being uh do everything that is
suggested now so I just make that
Proviso
uh but apart from that uh thank you for
the report what I would also just like
to suggest for future scrutiny reports
is that when it is a a non-statutry
um thing that's being reviewed that that
is identified in the report as a piece
of context because it's quite important
if the public are reading these reports
you know if it's a report about our bin
collections not being very good that is
a statutory Duty I believe whereas if
it's uh this for example it isn't I
think that is just to be useful to
highlight that in in future reports
thank you
thanks Council again yeah good point and
would agree with that it does um add to
the significance of it I think doesn't
it it is the key Point
um I'm happy to Second a really good
report and thank you obviously to all of
the um all of the members of the the
committee and the the officers who fell
into that
um any other comments on anyone else
Council ready yeah just just to say that
it wasn't the tourism such it was the
first ever strategy from this Council
um
it came in the middle of a pandemic and
we know how important the tourism and uh
so I know we're still committed to doing
that it's just been probably the worst
time ever for that industry and um
hopefully when that gets back on track
um reviewing some of these uh points
will certainly help us in terms of
guiding that through the next course
thanks thanks very much that's right
um okay all those in favor
okay that's carried uh the next paper is
the council plan uh targets performance
update for Quarter Two
um I mean the rough overview is that
we're doing quite well we've got
um 64 on track at the moment 35
previously achieved and then there's one
percent that we've achieved this time
um Taft is there anything that you want
to add to that or any it gives a brief
overview
uh and not so much detail this time as
you quite rightly point out most Target
well all Targets that are remaining are
on track and we've reported one that
we've uh signed off this time obviously
members are aware there's just six
months left of the current uh council
plan so lots of the targets that are in
there now are ones that we report an
annual outturn on so that's why there's
obviously quite a lot of targets still
in there but nothing of concern at this
point in time we know that the capacitor
living crisis will impact on some of
those targets so for instance reducing
the Leisure subsidy is going to be
particularly challenging this year uh
but members are aware of the context in
which the council is trying to deliver
the services so we'll obviously do the
updates each quarter and then obviously
there'll be the big refresh going
forward after the elections next year
thanks thanks Kath
um
uh so I'm happy to move the uh the
recommendations is there a second
okay so keep it thank you all those in
favor
okay that's carried uh and then the next
item is the medium-term uh financial
plan revised budget uh I'm gonna come to
Jane to talk us through this one so otj
thank you chair yes this is the revision
of the 2223 budget that was approved by
Council last January these revisions
will be incorporated into the mtfp
refresh that we're currently working on
that will be presented to Council next
January and in terms of the general fund
the budget was approved in January 22 as
I just said and it had a small Surplus
at that time of 49 000 pounds 10 account
of all the growths and efficiencies that
have been identified through the review
process and it's been a challenging one
this year we've now got a 343 000 pound
short form table one in the report goes
into those variances in some detail but
I'll just highlight the main ones and
they're the pay award which averaged
seven percent for the district this year
where we had an original forecast of two
percent that cost us an extra 18 on 816
000 pounds utilities of cost us an extra
448 000 pounds and fuel is nearly 200
000. as I said previously these
pressures are significant and were
largely unforeseen when we set the
budget last year
we've managed to identify most of those
as savings through the vacancy
management process this year
um and the shortfall has been funded
from the resilience Reserve I do however
expect that we'll be able to identify
further savings during the remainder of
the year to pay this back at the end of
this financial year
it is what the resilience Reserve was
created for just this eventually kind of
eventuality
um but as you'll know from previous
conversations that we've had about this
using the reserves is not sustainable
long term and we will be looking at this
as part of the medium-term financial
plan and the budget setting for next
year
in terms of the HRA there are no major
issues to report and in respect to the
capital program we've rolled over the
budgets from last year that were
approved by cabinet in July along with
the additions that have been approved
during the year by Council and I'm happy
to take any questions chair
okay thanks Jane uh any comments or
questions for you uh Council Redding
yes thank you Jane and I know that it's
um from uh from your point of view it's
been the last four years it's you've
gone from Christ to crisis my only slack
reservation is vacancy savings I
fundamentally believe it's a long term
of false economy
um I'd like to see that reviewed
um in the next six months because I
think carrying those long term stores
October for the future and actually
costs us more and that's that's seen in
many other organizations so so I
understand it short term I I'd really
like to be looked at long term
okay
if I may just come back on that chair
yet absolutely completely share that
view and it's something that that just
that just this morning that me and my
fellow directors were discussing it is a
false economy it is only short term and
we need a long-term plan so completely
agree and that's in hand
okay
um any other comments questions
no if not I'll uh I'll move the
recommendations is there a second day uh
Council Foster all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you uh and
then we come to development of an
Outreach community outreach service so
I'll hand over to councilor Cubit for
this one okay thank you chair
um I think this is mostly explained in
the report but obviously in recognition
of the increasing cost of living crisis
and um the difficulties that that many
residents are facing uh what as part of
our wider response
um The Proposal is to create a community
outreach service
um this is already in place at other
councils most notably bowls over locally
and uh it's so it's already sort of
um recognized by our environmental
health Team who would lead on this
um and basically the the sort of in a
nutshell what what the workers will do
is for the next two years they'll be
able to provide really targeted uh
support to uh families and sort of
individuals who are struggling
financially and it's sort of that going
that extra level to be able to sort of
help with form filling and things like
that because obviously there are a lot
of really good
um advice agencies and services already
within Northeast Derbyshire
um such as Citizens advice Etc but this
is just an extra sort of help for
residents and to be able to provide that
really wrap around target support for
families
um just to note that it is obviously
we've just discussed the budget and the
challenge is there but this would be
funded by the better care fund so it is
fully Grant funded and wouldn't add any
additional pressure I'm sure the section
151 officer is happy to to know so um
yeah I think
um I think this is a positive news story
for the council and in terms of The
Wider challenges that residents are
facing so I'm happy to to move the
report and I think the if cabinet agree
the next key thing is to signpost
Residence to that support because the
key thing is for residents to know uh
that they're there I've had multiple
conversations with with residents who
were sort of struggling about you know
whether they were getting everything
they were entitled to and and I've
signed posted that this was coming and
it's been received uh really positively
so far
brilliant thanks very much uh Council
Cooper I'm happy to uh to second I think
it's really good
um really good development and and
something that um all of our residents
and businesses will benefit from uh any
comments uh cancer already
yeah thanks uh Council Cupid I'm really
pleased to see this I think this is it
um bells and whistles I know we put a
lot of money into cab and uh little
Senator and many other agencies in terms
of Grants to help support residents and
really feel strongly about the amount of
people who are not collecting the
benefits that they're entitled to
um you know particularly pensioners and
pensioner credit you know the sort of
1250 pounds they would receive
additional uh and and I know in terms of
writtenal to our tenants and rignaled we
have a quite a strong team around them
and we would probably know quite a lot
of our residents in that respect and it
is that uh next couple pups families you
know holding down one or two jobs uh who
are just about managing and I do hope we
can get some um support maybe from
social services and trying to identify
the groups that were already in in need
of some extra support but how would we
then Target those who are not any of his
radar
thanks right back to you cancer keep it
yeah I completely agree Council renick
and I think um the idea of citing the
team within environmental health is that
they do sadly already come into contact
with the families who may need it well I
say sadly because obviously you
shouldn't need it but
um you know do need it so their best
place to be able to signpost in terms of
housing issues and things like that as
well
um so and Rental issues so I think that
will provide a cohort and then yeah the
the next key step is comms to members
and to the public so that they know that
service is there for them care thank you
very much uh cancer running just to
watch that because obviously uh also we
now have the um additional
responsibility in terms of private
landlords so I think that'd be really
another useful tie-in and perhaps some
uh I can forward that to um
to join dedic in terms of our catching
it with our homelessness strategy as
well because actually all those tie in
that uh no other strategy for those
who've quite a few months ago but that
tying in of all the agencies that joined
up thinking that's where we could really
impact one to one and try and bring
those together so I see a really useful
link to that anyway well done I think
that's a really really good positive
news brilliant thank you very much yeah
absolutely agree it's been moved in
second and I think this is a real uh
real uh bit of development and progress
for the council and it really marries in
well with our approach the cost of
living uh crisis and our to the desire
to do absolutely everything we can do as
local authorities to support our
residents through a really Torrid time
to be honest so yeah really really
support this really pleased it's come
forward uh all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried and then
we come to uh that's the agenda uh any
urgent items uh there are none and
therefore I'll move on to the exclusion
of the public so I'll move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them other exempt
information as defined in part one
schedule 12a to the Local Government Act
1972.
uh yeah that's it uh if we can turn off
the live stream then please